Isla, because this is a movie that involves ghosts
and seances, did anything haunted,
like, actually, it wasn't like
a haunted set or anything, was it?
Oh, funny, you should mention that.
There were a few moments that we thought
that the ghost of Noël Coward was walking among us.
One day, Leslie had to play the piano
and there was a door behind me and it just slammed shut
but there was no wind that day.
And then another time during the seance,
the lights went out mysteriously
and there was a power outage, which no one could explain.
We're all a bit cynical, but maybe Noël Coward
wasn't happy with some of the changes in the last act.
(laughs)
Well, I love learning about new things,
about the lovely people who are kind enough to come here.
And so, we were gonna play a game with Leslie and Isla,
where I get to know them a little better,
in a game called,
this is also what I love about people, Fun Facts.
(upbeat music)
But this one is, Face the Fun Facts
because we were gonna do a little crossover.
Here's how it works.
The fun fact is going to appear on the screen.
And I don't know if one is about Leslie
or one is about Isla.
And so then, I'm gonna guess
and then the person will reveal herself and explain.
Is that okay?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's see the first fun fact.
Let me face it.
(bell rings)
Okay, I wrote teenage romance novels with my mom
when I was a teenager.
Leslie.
(laughs)
(buzzer)
No.
(laughs)
Yes, I did.
And I had to write a love scene
and my mother may or may not have pitched
a certain sexual act,
that I was unfamiliar with myself
and I had to have my mom explain.
Let's just say, it's not fun writing sex scenes
when you're an inexperienced teenager, with your mother.
(laughs)
Yeah, I can agree with that.
Okay.
Let's see the next fun fact.
(bell rings)
I have bat-like hearing.
Oh, I'm gonna go with Isla.
No.
(buzzer)
Quite large ears, can't hear anything.
Its me.
I can hear every little, like, when Judd chews food,
I can hear like every, every little click
of his teeth, every time he like, you know,
does that, like opens his mouth.
Masticates.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm saying it with a disgusted look on my face.
(laughs)
You know what, it's real.
It can't all be like, oh my God,
we're married to the most amazing, funny men.
We need some annoying chewing here.
Yeah, right.
I mean, we've been together for 25 years.
So, I can hear every little thing, every little like,
he flicks his toes when we watch TV
and I can hear him like flicking his toes.
(laughs)
Okay.
The next fun fact is.
(bell rings)
I ride a unicycle.
I mean, I just went immediately to Isla.
(laughs)
(buzzer)
No, I'm wrong again, oh my God.
(laughs)
Leslie, I would have never known you rode a unicycle.
I can ride a unicycle.
I learned when I got a unicycle, when I was,
I think 10 or 11, for Christmas.
And I learned to ride, I can ride backwards.
I don't know if I still can ride backwards.
But I can jump off curbs.
I can, I don't know if I can do that anymore,
but I can ride, just ride a unicycle.
But I used to be really good at it.
Well, every time Judd starts chewing,
I suggest you hop on and get out of the room.
And ride away.
(laughs)
Okay.
(bell rings)
The next fun fact is,
I went to clown school and can juggle.
This is a bit of a cheat.
I know this about you Isla.
Yes.
(bell rings)
I got that one because I knew it.
I went to clown school.
And where, like somewhere fabulous right?
Paris?
In Paris I studied with a French clown called,
Jacques Lecoq, who discovered, Commedia Dell' Arte
from a little Italian village apparently
and brought it out into the world.
And actually, Sasha studied with a French clown called,
Philippe Gaulier, who studied with Lecoq also.
So that was something that we have in common.
That's so funny.
And Leslie just rides by on a unicycle.
(laughs)
And Judd's just clicking his toes in the back of the room.
And Judd's like.
(laughs)
Okay, last fun fact.
(bell rings)
My party trick is a pig noise.
Isla?
(laughs)
(pig noise)
Oh, it's so cute.
All right, I think we've come full circle.
And how perfect is that?
I just love getting to hang out with you guys.
So thank you for that.
Thank you.
Thanks for having us Drew.
Leslie Mann and Isla Fisher,
Blithe Spirit is available now
in select theaters and on digital and on demand.
And thank you both so much.
(upbeat music)